the way you just spoke to me was
straight up white supremacy you actually
just answered with racism so I want to
show a little bit of how all of this
wokeness that leads to this bizarre
guilt and an incapacitated group of
people who seemingly can't step up
against a bunch of 15-year-olds who
don't know what they're protesting about
uh how it's been pushed on us virtually
at every level there is a Girl by the
name of Sarah REO uh she is she's I
suppose big on Twitter as one of these
anti-racist people although everything
that she writes out is seemingly racist
she's she considers herself an American
radical political activist so of course
she got a TV show uh the TV show is
called race to dinner and yes it's as
bad as you think take a look you
actually Margaret you didn't say yours
what your racist thing thing that you've
done thought about or
done you have something inside of you
that's not quite like that's racist so
you must have you must have examples in
your your own life I also work in
environmental engineering I have
absolutely no people of color or minimal
people of color possibly the exclusion
being slightly
Hispanic s doesn't like her
attitudes I can say a racist thing
you've done because it just happened
when you just talked to me the way you
just did this is how white women talk to
us all the time these are
microaggressions when I say the exact
same thing to my white girlfriend who
says the same exact thing I don't care
if you talk to everybody like that the
way you just spoke to me was straight up
white supremacy you actually just
answered with racism white supremacy is
said to be hidden in innocuous phrases
and banile behavior the smallest things
could be considered racist it's enough
that a person from a minority group
feels insulted
absolutely sounding terribly white I
don't know that I was all that racist to
start with but I also would be more or
aware or hyper aware of my thoughts or
reactions to circumstances that would be
racist I have so many jokes and so many
comments that I wrote down I honestly
don't know where to start other than the
British guy who was doing the voice over
in honor of racism shot himself in the
head because he was an old white man at
the end of recording that thing Melissa
these people are so extraordinary
pathetic extraordinarily pathetic but
again they're just they're just reacting
to a society that has gone completely
wrong oh by the way they they pay her
$500 for that she doesn't pay them to
sit there they pay her $500 for the
privilege of having a meal where someone
tells you that you're a white
supremacist yeah okay do do you notice
how smug that woman was the one who's
accusing the poor white woman of of
being racist she was so smug she was
being a bully and this whole scene to me
looks like these are are are people that
have terrible
personalities that fine camouflage in
the IDE ideology like she's just using
this ideology to kind of bully this
woman and to talk to her in a way that's
just you know feeding her own narcissism
it seems like to me I mean James
probably knows more about this kind of
phenomenon but but that's just what what
it what it seems like it it is to me
that that it just gives you a license to
treat others which with cruelty with
such
viciousness am I am I right and it's
it's just evil like it's just it's James
please it's just patently evil what you
just watched just now was a MAA struggle
session But the irony is that Ma had to
throw people in prison to get them put
into conditions of struggle whereas
literally you can get awful white women
signing up to pay $500 a piece to
participate in their own struggle
session but the point of the struggle
session was that you had this this uh
social group around you that was going
to help you uh want to confess to these
crimes but you also had a interrogator
who would accuse you of crimes that in
in the the phrasing from from the
Chinese that you were not able to
recognize and so the goal was to help
you learn to recognize your crimes in
this case your crimes of racism which
were invisible to you and the goal is to
bully you and to Hound you and to create
a social environment where it feels like
there's a pressure for you to want to
confess and then the second you start to
confess the next stage is to say that
your confession is not sincere enough
and you continue to twist the thumb
screws the emotional and social thumb
screws until you get people like at the
end we saw the lady saying that she you
know she could be more aware I could
learn more about my My Invisible
crimes